[Music]
we start there with a bit of breaking
news a major announcement expected today
by President Joe Biden but before that
this morning as you see there
Congressman Dina Titus tweeted this Avi
Kwame will be recognized as a National
Monument today now we've talked about
this before Avi Kwame is also known as
Spirit Mountain it is down in the
southern tip of Nevada it is sacred land
for Native Americans the monument is
about 380 000 Acres this is roughly
around Laughlin again southern part of
Clark County making this a National
Monument protects it from development
we'll have a lot more on this
designation later on 8 news now this has
been an ongoing effort by Native
American tribes in the area not just in
Nevada but also in Arizona all across
the country essentially in the southwest
to get Spirit Mountain designated as a
National Monument it's been
controversial but it is apparently going
to be announced by President Biden later
today that's a large area down there too
380 000 Acres yes will be designated it
is